sur france 2 bonsoir et bienvenue à tous
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi une tente bédouine dressé à paris
le colonel kadhafi est arrivé en france
cet après midi au cours d'un premier
entretien nicolas sarkozy affirme avoir
évoqué avec lui les droits de l'homme et
annonce dix milliards d'euros de
contrats
une visite critiquée au sein même du
gouvernement rama yade parle de baiser
de la mort
le colonel kadhafi est-il fréquentable
notre invité ce soir claude guéant
secrétaire général de l'elysée où se
tient en ce moment le dîner de bienvenue
bonsoir et à tout à l'heure au tchad pas
de traitement de faveur pour les membres
de l'arche de zoé ils seront jugés
devant la cour criminelle dans les
prochaines semaines et risque jusqu'à 20
ans de travaux forcés en france une
nouvelle journée perturbée mercredi
quand les transports publics parisiens
suite à la grève la ratp prévoit la
suppression de 25 à 40% des rer des bus
ou des métros la réforme de l'ouverture
des magasins le dimanche est lancée
cette semaine première étape les
enseignes d'ameublement
le reste suivra en 2008 enfin alors qu
al gore reçoit son prix nobel de la paix
deux rapports simultanée évoque les
grandes villes menacées par la montée
des eaux et l'affaissement des terres
bangkok pourrait être noyé d'ici 15 à 20
ans il y à des visites officielles qui
ne passe décidément pas inaperçu
mouammar kadhafi est donc arrivé à paris
tout à l'heure il y restera cinq jours
le décorum vous allez le voir est
toujours très spectaculaire avec la
fameuse tente de tradition bédouine
mais c'est surtout le principe de ce
déplacement qui provoque la controverse
le récit de ces premières heures avec ça
m'a saoulé et franck brisset
34 ans que le colonel kadhafi n'avait
pas été accueillis en visite officielle
en france à l'aéroport d'orly c'est
michèle alliot marie ministre de
l'intérieur qui est chargé de
l'accueillir
une femme ministre pour le guide libyen
habitué à être entourée de sa célèbre
garde rapprochée féminine entrée hiver
et sable un cortège officiel imposant
pas moins de cent véhicules pour
transporter toute la délégation qui
accompagne muamar kadhafi hautement
sécurisé en tête du cortège
la limousine blanche de l'invité de la
france en route pour le palais de
l'elysée juste en face à l'hôtel de
marigny flotte déjà le drapeau libyen
une troupe de danseuses et deux
chanteurs bédouins il prend ses
quartiers sous l'oeil médusé de la
sécurité présidentielle c'est dans la
cour de cette résidence que le colonel
kadhafi a fait installer sa tente son
bureau en quelque sorte comme pour tout
chef d'état
la garde républicaine accueil muamar
kadhafi au palais de l'elysée l'ancienne
bête noire des occidentaux
commanditaires d'acte terroriste a
désormais droit aux honneurs de la
république le colonel kadhafi à
abandonner son programme nucléaire et
collaborent dans la lutte antiterroriste
c'est à cet homme-là que le président
français sert la main un accueil avec
tous les honneurs
quelques mois après la libération des
infirmières bulgares
une heure d'entretien au menu des
contrats d'armement mais également les
droits de l'homme
c'est bien beau les leçons de droits de
l'homme et les postures entre le café
flore et le zénith mais ses postures
elles ont laissé pendant huit ans et
malheureuse infirmières j'ai dit au
président kadhafi
combien il fallait continuer à
progresser sur le chemin des droits de
l'homme dans tous ses aspects tout ce
qu'il restait à faire des contrats
signés d'une valeur de 10 milliards
d'euros dont la livraison d'un réacteur
nucléaire pour une usine de dessalement
d'eau de mer
bonsoir michaël darmon vous êtes en
direct de l'elysée où se tient en ce
moment même un dîner de bienvenue quelle
est l'ambiance est-elle amical ou
simplement protocolaire bien coûter la
vie je dirais officiel ce qu'il faut
d'abord savoir ce que aujourd'hui on
dîne tôt à l'elysée en la réception a
commencé à 19h30 autour du colonel
kadhafi et est ce que l'on peut dire
également c'est bien c'est que cette ça
n'est pas le dîner le plus couru en
ville aujourd'hui il y a donc 80
personnes présents des chefs
d'entreprise quelques membres du
gouvernement michèle alliot marie
dominique bussereau nathalie kosciusko
morizet mais également on note surtout
l'absence remarquée donc du chef de la
diplomatie française bernard kouchner et
de rama yade secrétaire d'état aux
droits de l'homme
alors les contrats seront signés donc
après le dîner aux alentours de 20h30
vous voyez après cette journée chargée
en événements à l'elysée on ne souhaite
pas trop prolonger la soirée
merci michael il faut dire que cette
visite et ce retour en grâce du colonel
kadhafi on le disait suscite une vive
opposition à gauche
la nouveauté c'est que la critique a
gagné aussi les rangs du gouvernement
alexandre kara mathieu dreujou
pas question d'être une figurante ni ce
jour d'octobre darfour ni ce matin dans
la presse
face à l'avenue du colonel kadhafi rama
yade ne mâche pas ses mots avec une
journée les droits de l'homme sur les
bras et kadhafi sur le tarmac d'orly que
kadhafi devienne à paris d'accord mais
qu'on lui tienne un discours rigoureux
sur la question des droits de l'homme
c'est absolument indispensable parce que
la france n'est pas retenue balance
commerciale le colonel kadhafi style
fréquentable ou non sur cette question
bernard kouchner refuse de désavouer
rama yade
mais en ce moment je la soutiens mais
c'est ma secrétaire d'état et de temps
en temps un ministre des affaires
étrangères en vie une secrétaire d'état
qui peut parler ainsi des droits de
l'homme et s'il qualifie d' heureux
hasard cette réunion bruxelloise qui le
prive du dîner en l'honneur du colonel
kadhafi il défend néanmoins la ligne
officielle celle de la main tendue
un dirigeant qu'on espère devenu
raisonnable le président du modem lui
n'a pas ce problème de liberté de ton du
côté de l'ump on dit une seule chose
carnet de chèques carnet de chèques
carnet de chèques
il suffit qu'il y ait du pétrole ou du
gaz dans une de ces dictatures là pour
que aussitôt on s'abaisse on tire le
chapeau et on déploie le tapis rouge
ségolène royal condamne pour elle aussi
les droits de l'homme passent avant les
contrats déclaré kadhafi sur la question
du terrorisme et comment il l'a justifié
on sait aussi que le recevoir c'est
cautionner des pratiques de tortures en
prison et ça je crois que c'est pas
possible tout simplement pour la france
de donner cette image au reste du monde
les députés socialistes ont d'ailleurs
annoncé qu'il boycotterait demain la
réception du colonel kadhafi à la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale
mais les mots les plus retenus
aujourd'hui sont ceux très dur on l'a
entendu prononcer par rama yade
au point que certains se sont interrogés
sur une éventuelle démission
en fait après une convocation à l'elysée
la secrétaire d'état aux affaires
étrangères et aux droits de l'homme a
modéré ses propos
renaud bernard allain du bas
les salons du quai d'orsay rama yade
s'apprête à remettre le prix des droits
de l'homme le président de la république
vient de rappeler à l'ordre sa
secrétaire d'état
plus un mot sur le colonel kadhafi le
silence tue le silence fait le lit des
abus présents et à venir à l'encontre
des défenseurs des droits de l'homme
le silence est le meilleur allié de
l'oppression rama yade n'évoque plus la
libye mais ce qu'elle récompense le fond
à sa place comme ce militant des droits
de l'homme qui la félicite au nom des
prisonniers politiques libyens peu de
questions des rentrées dans le rang et
nicolas sarkozy peut réaffirmer sa
confiance en sa mine ce précieux jours
je vous savez la confiance et l'amitié
que j'ai pour rama yade
mais au sein de la majorité les propos
de rama yade sont quand même jugé
sévèrement inacceptable
j'ai les dix jeux le président la
république a reçu ce secrétaire d'état
et salles expliqué avec elle pour moi là
cédric l'eau l'incident est clos
rama yade a d'ailleurs fait savoir
qu'elle n'envisage pas de quitter le
gouvernement
alors on va retrouver dans un instant
ans claude guéant le secrétaire général
de l'elysée d'abord les raisons de cet
émoi on s'arrête un instant sur l'état
libyen quelle est exactement la
situation là-bas dans ce pays grand
comme trois fois la france mais qui
compte dix fois moins d'habitants
explication gérard griesbeck christophe
vignal il est resté un chef bédouin qui
reçoit toujours sous sa tente
officiellement il est le guide suprême
de la grande jamahiriya arabe libyenne
populaire et socialiste
c'est à dire la libye il est aussi chef
des armées avec le grade de colonel
charismatique kadhafi tentent depuis
presque 40 ans d'imprégner sa marque sur
l'histoire à la tête d'un pays trois
fois plus grand que la france mais
presque entièrement désertique
la libye est un pays riche grâce à ses
réserves de gaz et de pétrole
il est le deuxième producteur africain
de pétrole après le nigeria avec dans
ses caisses 150 milliards d'euros pour
honorer toutes sortes de contrats à
l'étranger
le pays a donc changé grâce à cet argent
la population un peu plus de cinq
millions d'habitants s'est alphabétisés
kadhafi a écrit un livre le livre vert
qui mieux qu'une constitution sert de
modèle celui du pouvoir populaire
en réalité c'est le pouvoir d'un homme
d'un clan kadhafi longtemps chef
terroriste a accepté en 2003 de tourner
la page mais son régime reste une
dictature
pas de partis d'opposition des dizaines
voire des centaines de prisonniers
politiques comme les infirmières
bulgares torturée en prison où ses
militants des droits de l'homme détenus
sans procès mady avocat idriss médecin
farid écrivain bonsoir claude guéant
vous êtes en direct de l'elysée merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
l'elysée où se tient donc en ce moment
même ce dîner de bienvenue pour le
colonel kadhafi on découvre quelques
images ici de son arrivée le colonel
kadhafi at il fait suffisamment de
chemin pour justifier un tel accueil de
la france à l'accueil que lui ont
réservé aucun des grands pays
occidentaux jusqu'à présent cet accueil
et l'accueil qui est réservé à tous les
chefs d'état qui sont en visite en
france
cette visite pose surtout une question
de principe et une question de
responsabilité
que devons-nous faire à l'égard de pays
qui se sont mal comportés dans le passé
est ce que nous devons les laisser
s'enfoncer dans leur solitude et dans
leurs errements
ou bien ce que nous devons les aider à
se soustraire à ces comportements que
nous condamnons c'est exactement le
problème que nous avons avec la libye la
libye nous le savons a dans le passé
frayer avec le terrorisme la libye a eu
des comportements condamnables
la libye s'était doté d'un arsenal
nucléaire et d'armes chimiques
contrairement aux règlements
internationaux aujourd'hui la libye
lutte avec la france avec toutes les
démocraties occidentales contre le
terrorisme alors qu'elle a renoncé à
toutes les armes de destruction massive
et la position du président sarkozy
c'est que compte tenu des signes de la
volonté de la libye et de son chef le
colonel kadhafi de se sortir des erreurs
du passé
eh bien il faut l'aider à se sortir des
erreurs du passé alors faire en sorte
que la libye participe au respect des
règles internationales
vous parlez un d'être faits ou parler
claude guéant des erreurs du passé mais
il y a quelques heures quelques jours à
peine seulement le connais lesquelles
kadhafi déclarait estimé qu'il était
normal que les faibles et recours au
terrorisme est ce qu'il a vraiment
changé
écoutez c'est un commentaire ce n'était
pas du tout une profession de foi
le colonel kadhafi a encore certainement
avec son pays des progrès à faire dans
la lho voie de la démocratie dans la
voie du respect des libertés
individuelles dans la voie de ce que
nous nous considérons comme les
principes juridiques fondamentaux le
président sarkozy n'a pas manqué de le
lui rappeler d'ailleurs lors de leur
première réunion de travail en début
d'après midi
mais encore une fois et dont ce pays à
nous rejoindre dans nos principales
conception au lieu de le contraindre à
s'enfoncer dans les rangs vous avez été
au coeur de la libération des
infirmières bulgares vous vous êtes
rendus sur place vous avez participé aux
négociations
est ce que cette visite n'est pas la
contrepartie aujourd'hui accordée par la
france à cette libération
ce n'est pas une contrepartie le
président sarkozy avait dit clairement
au colonel kadhafi qu'il invitait en
libye que il était hors de question
qu'il se rende en libye avant que les
infirmières bulgares et le médecin
palestinien ne soit libéré ce qui est
une position je suis né au passage très
différente de celle adoptée par beaucoup
d'autres responsables occidentaux qui
s'était rendu en libye
averts alors même que les infirmières
étaient encore détenus et certains
d'entre eux profité de leur passage en
libye pour réclamer certes la libération
des infirmières mais en même temps signé
des contrats d'armement
le président sarkozy a une position très
claire il est maintenant possible
d'avoir des relations normales avec la
libye
c'est souhaitable y compris pour
l'équilibré de cette région du reste
n'oublions pas que dans la région tout à
côté de la libye il y a le darfour à une
beaucoup de gens des femmes des enfants
sont en train de mourir de faim et de
mourir des effets de la guérilla alors
et vous avez et n'importe que la libye
apporte sa contribution à la sécurité et
à la protection des droits de l'homme
dans cette région
parce que la vie des hommes c'est quand
même d'abord la première des protections
septe visite vous l'avez entendu un
suscité des grincements de dents des
critiques même très vive au sein même du
gouvernement
vous avez entendu rama yade elle a été
convoquée à l'elysée
est ce que nicolas sarkozy a fait la
leçon est ce que vous même vous
condamner ces propos
écoutez la voix de la france est
exprimée par le président de la
république madame yade ce matin à
exprimer une sensibilité mais pas la
voix de la france
dernière chose on a vu les félicitations
au téléphone à vladimir poutine
la visite en chine aussi qui dans un
autre registre a provoqué certaines
interrogations est ce que nicolas
sarkozy n'a pas abandonné la diplomatie
des valeurs qu'il prônait pendant la
campagne électorale pour une réelle
diplomatie plus proche des intérêts
directs et notamment des intérêts
économiques en aucune façon je rappelle
qu'en russie il a rencontré une ong dont
la vocation est le respect des droits de
l'homme au risque de provoquer un
incident diplomatique avec les autorités
russes
lorsqu'il était en chine il a et c'était
le premier chef d'état occidental à le
faire demander publiquement un certain
nombre de progrès dans le respect des
droits de l'homme par exemple la fin de
la peine de mort dans ce pays
dans le même temps il estime qu'il est
absolument indispensable de parler aux
gens pour faire en sorte qu'ils
progressent sur ne parle pas avec eux on
n'a aucune chance de les faire aller
dans les directions que nous souhaitons
merci claude guéant d'avoir répondu à
nos questions soir donc en direct de
l'elysée deuxième titre de l'actualité
le sort des français de l'arche de zoé
détenus au tchad
le juge d'instruction a tranché ils
seront tous renvoyés devant la cour
criminelle ainsi que trois tchadien et
un soudanais
la peine encourue est très lourde
jusqu'à 20 ans de travaux forcés et le
procès pourrait se tenir avant la fin
année amaury guibert michel hiver de
leur prison de djamena les membres de
l'arche de zoé espérer la clémence
ils devront répondre de leurs actes
devant un jury populaire
le juge d'instruction a terminé son
enquête il vient de renvoyer devant une
cour criminelle les six français de
l'association mais aussi trois
intermédiaires tchadien et un soudanais
les charges retenues sont lourdes
enlèvement de mineur escroquerie faux en
écriture et parce que l'arche de zoé n'a
pas payé certains loyers grivèlerie en
france les proches des accusés craignent
à cette décision
la femme d'alain péligat et d'ailleurs
jointe à la grève de la faim observée
depuis samedi par les détenus au tchad
pour dénoncé une enquête bâclée beaucoup
de preuves à décharge rapport à l'art
j'ai joué et été négligée et on a peur
d'un jugement hâtif et qui serait sévère
mais une enquête internationale a aussi
révélé que presque tous les enfants
recueillis par l'arche de zoé ne sont
pas des orphelins du darfour comme
l'association le disait la défense
entend maintenant plaider la bonne foi
on est dans un procès qui ne tient pas
compte de l'essentiel à savoir que ces
hommes et ces femmes ont agi
fondamentalement pour faire du bien le
juge a aussi prononcé une série de
non-lieu attendu pour les trois
journalistes
l'équipage de l'avion espagnol affrété
par l'arche de zoé
le pilote belge et un responsable
tchadien
le procès lui devrait se tenir très
rapidement sans doute la semaine
prochaine
en bref la suite du voyage de françois
fillon en argentine le premier ministre
a eu une série d'entretiens sur le sort
d'ingrid betancourt il a notamment
rencontré le président colombien alvaro
uribe et lui a demandé de prendre des
initiatives
ce dernier a lancé un nouvel appel aux
farc les ravisseurs en leur demandant de
libérer les otages mais sans avancer de
nouvelles propositions en russie
vladimir poutine a désigné son
successeur c'est son vice premier
ministre dmitri medvedev qui sera le
candidat du parti au pouvoir à la
présidentielle de mars prochain retenez
donc ce nom il a 42 ans il est réputé
libéral
rappelons que vladimir poutine ne peut
être candidat lui-même pour des raisons
constitutionnelles à moscou laurent
boussier xavier luizet voici donc un
visage auxquels il va falloir s'habituer
dimitri medvedev 42 ans ancien directeur
de l'administration du kremlin et actuel
vice premier ministre un cv en or pour
ce juriste fidèles de l'actuel chef de
l'état
je le connais très bien 2017 temps où on
a travaillé ensemble très étroitement
pendant toutes ces années il je soutiens
pleinement sa candidature santé logement
éducation depuis deux ans dimitri
medvedev était en russie l'homme du
social président du géant gazier gazprom
il est aussi l'homme des milieux
d'affaires dans l'entourage de vladimir
poutine il est surtout un des rares à ne
pas être issu de l'ex kgb ou d'un autre
salle ans de sécurité en désignant comme
son successeur dimitri medvedev vladimir
poutine a fait le choix d'un homme
intelligent mais qui n'a derrière lui
aucun des puissants clans du kremlin
un homme de compromis que l'actuel
président russe pourra à sa guise dirigé
depuis les coulisses en france
l'actualité sociale la ratp a donné ses
prévisions pour la grève des transports
notez le bien si vous habitez en région
parisienne elle aura lieu mercredi après
demain entre 60 et 80% en des bus des
métros ou des rer resteront en
circulation le dta julien beaumont 1
vassili cani une grève pour peser sur
les négociations
voilà comment la cgt ratp justifie le
mouvement social qui aura lieu mercredi
la cgt ratp qui est la seule appelés à
débrayer pour les prévisions prévoyaient
en moyenne 60% du trafic dans le métro
et le rer b
bien mieux que le 14 novembre dernier
où pratiquement aucune rame ne circulait
mercredi compter sur 75% des rer à 80 %
des bus et tramways devraient rouler une
dernière rencontre est prévue demain
entre direction syndicats et
représentants de l'état en cas d'accord
le préavis de grève pourrait être levé
côté sncf c'est jeudi qu'aura lieu le
mouvement social là aussi contre la
réforme des régimes spéciaux troisième
grève en trois mois mais cette fois ci
uniquement à l'appel de la cgt et de la
cgc profs que le front syndical est
divisée sur ce sujet une grève que la
présidente de la sncf jugent
incompréhensible et inutile
ce sont ces mots on devrait connaître
les prévisions de trafic de la sncf
demain la sncf qui vient par ailleurs de
lancer une nouvelle opération de
recrutement dans les banlieues c'est la
deuxième année consécutive
l'enjeu est clair on en parle beaucoup
il s'agit de diversifier le personnel
d'ouvrir ses portes
cette démarche volontariste est un
succès plus de mille personnes ont été
recrutées de cette manière en un peu
plus d'un an et demi ça bien shadow
marie cros il ya six mois
gitana eighty d'hyères connaissait la
sncf comme n'importe quel usager cieux
aujourd'hui ce bac +5 de 28 ans dirige
une équipe d'une trentaine de personnes
chargées de la maintenance des eurostar
et des thalys
jérôme et arnaud sur le convoyeur 2 et 4
avoir des responsabilités
voilà ce qu'il recherchait en postulant
la sncf terme fonctionnaires pour
complètement le bar est parce qu on fait
des heures on a beaucoup de pression
mais c'est pour la bonne cause c'est une
pression très positive rida a été
recruté en juin dernier
aujourd'hui ils épaulent les futures
recrues
vous êtes le responsable de demain et ça
c'est pas que des mots je sens que parce
qu'ils viennent de quartiers a mauvaise
réputation parce que lors nous ne sommes
pas français
même s'ils ont tous bac +4 leur cv fini
trop souvent à la poubelle pour court
circuiter les habitudes de certains
recruteurs
la sncf va directement à leur rencontre
on va se donner une quinzaine de minutes
pour mieux saisir vos motivations pour
l'entreprise depuis un an et demi
la sncf a recruté plus de 1000 personnes
issues des quartiers défavorisés
ce jour là ils sont deux cents voilà ce
qu'ils viennent chercher la confiance
qu'on compte dans la journée
jeunes issus de l'immigration jeunes
des zones en panne d'essence à l'issue
des entretiens
un quart des candidats sera sélectionné
pour une dernière série de tel alors sur
la visite avant de signer peut-être un
contrat comme rida il ya six mois enfin
toujours à propos de la sncf une image
de marseille c'est aujourd'hui que la
nouvelle gare saint-charles a été
inaugurée après dix ans de travaux 160
mètres de long 60 4 colonnes de pierre
et une grande façade vitrée images
signées de notre peau cependant sur
place christophe l'art aucun en bref
encore à propos de transport un nouveau
chiffre encourageant pour la sécurité
routière le nombre de tués a diminué de
2% au mois de novembre par rapport à
l'an passé
et globalement depuis le début de
l'année la baisse est également de 2%
la réforme de l'ouverture des magasins
le dimanche est lancée cette semaine
première étape les enseignes
d'ameublement
le reste suivra en 2008 quel est l'enjeu
économique qui est concerné avec quel
salaire explication séverine lebrun
tout comme ses salariés d'un grand
magasin de région parisienne
12% des français travaillent
régulièrement le dimanche
une proportion qui monte à 39% dans le
commerce à savoir une journée de repos à
melle
or la poule
pourtant selon le code du travail le
dimanche est un jour de repos c'est la
règle alors tout travail ce jour là fait
l'objet d'une dérogation
d'abord dans les commerces alimentaires
dans les industries qui ne peuvent pas
stoppé leur production et dans 39
secteurs comme les restaurants ou les
fleuristes on peut travailler tous les
dimanches
c'est un jour comme les autres qui ne
donne pas forcément droit à un salaire
majoré deuxième type de dérogation les
zones touristiques
autre exception enfants pour tous les
autres commerces
il est possible d'ouvrir au maximum cinq
dimanches par an pendant les périodes de
fêtes notamment et dans ce cas là c'est
sur la base du volontariat avec un
salaire double comme il n'est pas
question de revenir sur le principe du
dimanche jour de repos d'autres
dérogations sont encore à l'étude dans
les magasins d'ameublement par exemple
autoriser plus de dimanche travaillé
notamment dans les grandes
agglomérations dans certains commerces
un quart du chiffre d'affaires est
engrangée en fin de semaine josé bové
n'ira pas en prison sa peine de quatre
mois ferme pour arrachage ogm a été
converti en jours amende
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle en
a pris acte et a immédiatement annoncé
qu'il ne baissait pas les bras il
observera une grève de la faim avec
d'autres militants à partir du 3 janvier
après les fêtes pour réclamer un
moratoire sur ces mêmes ogm un réel
moratoire selon ses termes
les suites de la grosse tempête qui
s'est abattue hier sur l'ouest de la
france
les promeneurs de ce lundi ont pu
découvrir sur les côtes de bretagne des
paquets en tout genre tombé des bateaux
des à nana du tabac et des boîtes de
lait en poudre se sont échouées sur les
plages
christelle bertrand non non vous n'êtes
ni victime d'hallucinations ni d' abus
de boisson
c'est bien l'ananas la pêche du jour
dans le port de trébeurden un peu
surpris au début les voisins du port se
sont vite équipés pour le ramassage
exotiques
j'adore la nana et c'est bon pour le
bois et là tout à fait par hasard comme
on vient souvent au fort se promener on
a vu des changes donc on s'est arrêté et
puis voilà on va y réfléchir accuse donc
on a fait pareil les fruits étaient
transportés dans des conteneurs éventrée
par la tempête puis échoué dans le port
un peu plus à l'ouest ce sont des
milliers de paquets de tabac à rouler
qui ont fait le bonheur des promeneurs à
terre la tempête a fait quelques dégâts
l'électricité devrait vite être rétabli
même pour les foyers les plus isolées
la remise des prix nobel 2007 à
stockholm la cérémonie a eu lieu ce
matin le roi de suède a notamment remis
aux français albert fert son prix de
physique également récompensé doris
lessing en littérature et aussi bien sûr
al gore qui a obtenu le prestigieux
nobel de la paix avec les experts en
climatologie du giec et cela alors que
les scientifiques d'autres scientifiques
sur ce même thème sont réunis à bali
pour faire des propositions sur les
mesures à prendre face aux changements
climatiques
c'est dans ce contexte que deux rapports
simultanée de l'onu et de l' ocde aborde
la menace qui pèse sur des dizaines de
grandes villes du monde menace d'être
noyée par la montée des eaux et
l'affaissement des terres selon l'un de
ces rapports bangkok par exemple
pourraient disparaître d'ici quinze ou
vingt ans jean françois feer est eric de
l'agneau les digues aujourd'hui ne
suffisent plus à marée haute les eaux de
l'océan indien piège ce temple
bouddhiste proche de bangkok
trop tard pour le sauver mais les moines
comme les fidèles refuse pourtant de
l'abandonner
cette dame conserve les photos prises
lors de la dernière tempête
selon elle les preuves que la métropole
est en train de couler bangkok aura
complètement disparu dans think they
live nous l'ont lu c'est on voit bien
que ça dit chaque ans mais dans le
centre de la ville
personne ne veut nous croire la taille
ou à bangkok
l'eau monte chaque année de 3 mm par an
conjuguée à un autre phénomène la ville
s'enfonce à force de creuser dans le sol
bangkok 6 million et demi d'habitants
pourrait être rayé de la carte d'ici
quinze ou vingt ans
cette zone d'asie du sud est la plus
menacée du globe comme l'afrique de
l'ouest où les états unis à plus longue
échelle dans le pire des cas
voici ce qui arrivera en floride les
pays bas eux pourraient totalement
sombré et la construction de nouvelles
digues me changera rien si d'aventuré il
arrivait au cours des prochains siècles
et peut-être même plutôt que la calotte
du groenland ne fonde ses six à sept
mètres d'augmentation du niveau de la
mer auquel il faudrait s'attendre
bien avant cette échéance l'exode
climatique a déjà commencé comme ici au
bangladesh en 2070 150 millions de
personnes pourraient être touchées et
les pays du nord les plus riches sont
également concernés voici un exemple
directement visibles à l'oeil nu il
s'agit de l'archipel des auteurs bank's
aux états unis en caroline du nord très
prisée par les touristes
des dizaines de maisons une route bref
un village entier est en train de
disparaître sur place envoyés spéciaux
alain de chalvron aaron diamond si vous
voulez une maison les pieds dans l'eau
on vous attend dans les outer banks et
îles barrières à la beauté sauvage en
caroline du nord
les pieds dans l'eau ces maisons les ont
littéralement un peu trop même en fait
elles n'en ont plus pour longtemps
on a beau les protégés avec des sacs de
sable la bataille est perdue d'avancé
pour regarder des images et rien de 2002
vous verrez une rangée complet de maison
et la rue orionis tri qui longeait la
plage par là il ya tout juste cinq ans
willy à cinq ans et tout a disparu
oui tout a disparu c'est une cause
perdue dans les deux prochaines années
ces maisons ne seront plus là quand j'ai
acheté ma première maison il ya une
vingtaine d'années il y avait à peu près
50 mètres de plage et chaque année
l'érosion en grignote 2 mètres 50
c'est vrai que j'aurais dû faire
attention un peu plus attention quand je
les ai achetées aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
d'autre choix que d'essayer de les
sauver avec ses sacs de sable j'ai mis
des centaines de milliers de dollars là
dedans et ça n'a pas réussi c'est sans
espoir
l'accélération du phénomène est
impressionnant il y a deux ans ici
c'était une route
il n'en reste plus que ces traces de
bitume et les maisons qu'il abordait son
sous le sable en accusation le
réchauffement de la planète
nous savons que le réchauffement de la
planète
l'intensité et la durée des ouragans
n'ont jamais été aussi élevés nous
savons qu'en raison du réchauffement
climatique la fonte des glaces polaires
et des glaciers pourraient faire
augmenter le niveau de la mer pour les
cinq ans à venir et que cela met en
danger l'existence même des outer banks
comme dans d'autres endroits dans le
monde
dans l'immédiat paradoxalement le
réchauffement de la planète n'a pas que
des inconvénients les 35000 habitants
permanents de l'île vivent presque
exclusivement du tourisme et bénéficie
d'un allongement sensible de la saison
avec de nouveaux touristes vont venir
par ici pour voir saisi il avant
qu'elles ne disparaissent donc sur le
court terme c'est une source de revenus
supplémentaires
mais sur le long terme ce qui importe le
plus c'est l'environnement et la
sauvegarde et ils dans leur sagesse les
habitants des outer banks ont rejeté par
référendum les solutions coûteuses et
sans effets à long terme de renflouement
permanent des plages en espérant qu'à
réveil des consciences permettra de
limiter les conséquences du
réchauffement de la planète et sauver
leur fragile banc de sable avant qu'il
ne soit trop tard
deux drames de l'immigration clandestine
un bateau parti de turquie vers la grèce
a fait naufrage la nuit dernière il ya
51 morts on ne connaît pas leur
nationalité
un autre naufrage au large du sénégal a
fait plusieurs dizaines de victimes
suite à la tempête
l'embarcation se diriger vers les
canaries cette question de l'immigration
provoque une crispation chez nos voisins
italiens dans certaines villes des élus
locaux de la ligue du nord impose des
conditions très strictes à
l'installation des étrangers même légaux
en vénitie envoyés spéciaux philippe
visseyrias karine billom on le surnomme
déjà le shérif de città del depuis
quelques jours tous les étrangers qui
s'installent dans cette petite ville de
vénétie reçoivent la visite de monsieur
le maire et de sa police municipale
comme cette roumaine les nouveaux
arrivants doivent désormais prouver que
leur logement est en bon état on vérifie
l'eau la lumière les pièces ils doivent
également fournir des bulletins de paye
prouvant qu'ils gagnent au moins 420
euros par mois et par personne
nous voulons éviter que des gens qui ne
travaillent pas s'installe chez nous car
nous pensons que ces gens là viennent
pour voler mais massimo bitocci est allé
plus loin il a créé une commission
municipale qui doit statuer sur la
dangerosité de chaque étranger arrivant
à tchita d'elle une initiative bloqué
par la justice italienne qui le poursuit
pour usurpation de fonction bien à
l'abri derrière ses remparts médiévaux
citadelle à la citadelle en italien n'a
jamais aussi bien porté son nom dans
sept villes prospères du nord de
l'italie où le chômage n'existe pas le
drapeau de la ligue du nord parti
d'extrême droite flotte sur la place
principale et l'initiative du maire
plaît aux habitants les étrangers sont
des voleurs dans mon quartier ils ont
abîmé nos voitures on ne peut pas leur
faire confiance
dans les locaux de la cgl principal
syndicat italien
les militants qui viennent en aide aux
travailleurs immigrés sont consternés en
vénétie vivent des centaines de milliers
de travailleurs immigrés tout à fait en
règle avec la loi
ceux qui sont des délinquants sont une
minorité il n'y a pas de barbara nos
portes ça il vit dans la région depuis
vingt ans ses trois enfants sont nés ici
jamais ce marocain n'avait connu un tel
climat de méfiance
on nous traite de délinquant mais ce
n'est pas vrai nous les immigrés nous
payons nos cotisations sociales et nous
contribuons à la croissance de lycée ni
in italy dans son bras de fer contre
l'état le maire de tchita dell a obtenu
le soutien d'une cinquantaine de
communes de la région qui ont annoncé
qu'elles allaient prendre le même arrêté
municipal
en italie toujours routes et autoroutes
bloquées les chauffeurs ont entamé une
grève de cinq jours à la frontière
italo-française au niveau du péage de
vintimille des poids lourds ont été
garés en travers de la route les
voitures peuvent passer mais les
grévistes empêchent les camions d'entrer
en france les routiers italien
protestent notamment contre la hausse
des carburants
on en vient à la chanson du dimanche
c'est une illustration du phénomène
net et qui provoque une ruée sur les
écrans tous les week-ends deux
internautes trentenaire inconnu
jusque-là composent chaque semaine
chaque fin de semaine une chanson
humoristique qui provoque des centaines
de milliers de connexions
ils sont en train de devenir des
vedettes mallory ahounou daniel levy
seiler incontournable de ce dimanche des
amateurs élu mister un gars pas du tout
voici les nouvelles stars du net
un prof de maths et un intermittent deux
amis publicité parce qu'ils écrivent
pour rigoler ma chance on a envie de
vraiment faire un tube à chaque semaine
on s'est dit on va faire un tube un
véritable défi relevé grâce à internet
leurs titres sont mis en ligne chaque
dimanche plus téléchargé que les
journaux télé ils ont déjà été vue près
de deux millions de fois le bouche à
oreille a décollé avec un tulle de
bouche de métro cheminots pendant les
grèves
miss france hier matin des thèmes dans
l'air du temps plus les gic engagé pour
se renouveler chaque semaine disque
audio scouts du rhône lecture ça a
commencé avec les élections
présidentielles
c'est vrai qu'avant n'y avait pas
forcément c'était pas autour de
l'actualité et on a été rattrapé par
l'actualité
c'est vrai que c'est quand même une
source d'inspiration j'allais pouvoir
d'achat compose on peut faire une
mélodie accrocheuse un bon frein qu'on a
envie de chanter pendant la semaine
l'habitat perdu mon temps sur scène avec
un autre groupe
le dieu se fait désormais applaudir le
dimanche après la grasse mat une
invasion virtuel mais enthousiaste à la
ccin commentaires pour l'instant c'est
pour aller voir la chanson les lundis
zannier la grand messe du dimanche
souvenir du cac a rendu une bonne humeur
pour toi les chanteurs du dimanche je
voudrais maintenant transposer le
concept en télé ou en radio
leur histoire d'humour ne devrait pas
s'arrêter si c'est une image de sport
c'est une victoire qui fait du bien le
psg s'est imposé 1 0 face à auxerre en
match en retard de la 17e journée de
ligue 1 but de la tête signé luyindula
les parisiens sortent de la zone de
relégation le voici au ralenti ce but et
puis fernando alonso est de retour chez
renault le pilote de formule 1 disputera
le championnat 2008 avec le constructeur
français aux côtés du brésilien nelson
piquet fils de son père en bref à
l'occasion de la journée mondiale des
droits de l'homme reporters sans
frontières publie ce nouvel album photos
sans clichés d'enfants des scènes de
rues d'ici ou d'ailleurs signé sabine
weiss
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui 130
journalistes sont emprisonnés dans le
monde
un album à découvrir dans tous les
kiosques au prix de 9 euros 90 avant de
refermer cette édition je vous en
rappelle l'un des principaux titres
le colonel kadhafi a entamé en dans cet
après midi son voyage en france
visite critiquée au sein même du
gouvernement rama yade parle de baiser
de la mort
sur ce plateau tout à l'heure claude
guéant secrétaire général de l'elysée
indiqué que la secrétaire d'état
exprimait une sensibilité mais pas la
voix de la france c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo nathalie rihouet 20h50
fbi portés disparus n'oubliez pas à
23h15 complément enquête autour de
benoît duquesne caisses noires dessous
de table la france dépôt train à demain
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr
autre soirée sur france 2 le voilà qu'il
ait déjà vu dans le parc avec ça